juli sind jelly beans und hier oben
achtung ist auch so ein teil drauf
gesetzt sind willkommen zu einem neuen
video leute ich habe im sommer 2010
schon mal ein video gemacht wo ich mit
jana die verrücktesten süßigkeit
getestet habe da gar kein gummi mit
ketchup füllung hier diese sommer 2008
sind wir dann wieder eingekauft wir sind
angelaufen in einen äusserst glaube ich
haben uns die verrückteste scheiße
rausgesucht die wir da gefunden haben
und testen die ersten aber selbstständig
heute kann ich ganz sache nicht allein
machen ich brauchte verstärkung von
einem süßigkeiten experten können wir
kurz die universitätsabschluss
süßigkeiten testerin die clown zeigen
dann ja dann würde ich sagen wir machen
ich geb dir mal die erste süßigkeit die
ich im regal gesehen habe wo ich mir
gedacht habe was zum thema hier ist
sieht aus wie dieser hat stefan raab
also die sache heißt mega hypno spray
candy
stefan cappenberg mal okay dann machen
wir das ding hier um einmal auch erst
mal dieses mega groß dass diese ganzen
dinge wie das wasser in die augen
welchen sinn macht dass das projekt den
mund meinte die hypnose funktioniert
müssten nicht ganz normal stehen wir
auch
das motiviert haben
das haben sie jetzt sagt was ja hallo
aussprechen so sterilen ja ich würde
gerne sicherstellen dass ich weg dass
die oberrhein können dann machen wir
jetzt weiter mit einem sehr praktischen
alltagsgegenstand den ich auf jeden fall
da im süßigkeiten regal entdeckt hat und
zwar braucht man also übrigens das
dinkelsbühler pop erstmal auch herd
beigeschmack muss man auch seine zone
bewegen bereitet er sich quasi selbst im
ankurbelt
[Musik]
einfach lieber ich merke das sieht auch
keine auf jeden fall leute wenn ihr im
unterricht ich dinge ausgepackt habe und
ein lehrer todes abgefragt haben wir
zehn minuten lang und das macht was wird
als nächstes letzten jahr das ist so
eine schraube zeug eine beraterin damit
dass er irgendwo einen schaum spray
komplett schaue ich brauche jedoch nicht
gar nicht jetzt kenne ich ja mal gar
nicht besser schmeckt wir werden mal ein
apfel ist werden noch so apfel hughes im
unter den runterschlucken ganz viel
spucke so schnell das richtige spucke
probieren das ist eigenartig der stern
einmal niebels korrekt dieses bild hier
drauf einfach so ein feuerwehrmann
ich hab mir klickt man direkt bock immer
mehr branchen mehr
das ist so eigenartig warum gibt es das
ja ich sag jetzt kurz vor sich denke
danach will keiner werfen uns
ausprobieren dafür das zeug ist so
ekelhaft es schmeckt als hätte jemand
anders einen center schock gegessen und
hätte euch dann in den fucking bund
gespuckt ja so schmeckt alles in den
mund gesprüht
ich werde mir wechsel leute praxis vier
jahre eingesprungen ohne wird das hier
ist das fach in eclipse und jemals
gegessen süßigkeiten ich bin neugierig
wie das breakers auf handy dringt die
rolle
das funktioniert genauso hinterher oder
muss ich die richtung aber entspannt ich
kurz stellen ich wollte die rolle der
reform geht ja stimmen bringen
das rät ihr nicht drüber weg
funktioniert halt nicht das ding das
problem nehmen das andere
der trick ist ein trick den offiziellen
imst ins maul youtube mit unseren zehn
mann drückt man auf dem pferd man den
zuschuss konzentriert korrekt heutige
christlich das ist auch so eine
süßigkeit da muss ich sagen das ist auf
jeden fall das zweite kekse von dem was
wir daten oder finden so schnell die
leute kommen jetzt zu meinen fans haben
zwar dass die jelly beans oder so die
süßigkeit ist ja ich habe das spiel ein
und hier oben ab donnerstag zum teil
drauf
[Musik]
kann mir da dass diese also wir fassen
zusammen dieses komische ding hier oben
dreht sich dann spielt einfach irgend so
ein song und anna lena wird dort drei
nicht mal original jelly beans das herz
macht sich ob sich lohnt das teuerste
teil ist kostet 23 euro oder so jetzt
nicht so intensiv verdienten aber sieht
geil aus
es gibt aber auch leute ratet mal in den
kommentaren was dieses geräusch ist
die kommentare was sie denkt was es ist
ich bin gespannt ob überhaupt ein mensch
meiner community leute in the dark
anleitung zum effekt leicht knicken
schütteln scheinbar ist dann kläglich
das sind cool aussehen wie er oder sie
und scheinbar muss man das schütteln und
dann ist es so etwas sollte sich
ausgehen um süßigkeiten zu verkaufen und
das deine lebensmittel zulassung dieses
kläglich vergibt sieht man das leuchtet
dass man einen dunklen raum gehen dass
man den maschinenraum gegner testen okay
heute bin erstmal den komplett irgendein
traumreisen quadratmeter sieht man
irgendwas wenn man sieht die leute drin
ziffernblatt leuchtet ein paar ziffern
bedeutet und ja das war
nein wieso wieder ablecken hier bist du
im dunkeln ablecken dass man auf jeden
fall nach mexiko und du hast irgendwie
so zog man das so sieht es aus leute
über es gab ja diese sauren kristall da
und ich muss sagen das ist eigentlich
mein bisher
walter meisten so die anderen sachen
waren wir bis hin zu gehört das war
soweit dieser test was du deine
verbringt markt das ist ein favorit
erster vorzimmer des letzter platz für
dich der apfel schwang sich der abschaum
zählen bei mir leute letzter platz ist
auf jeden fall dieses zeug hier what the
[ __ ] und erster platz haben wir auch
ganz klar diese dinge die das was von
diesem video max eine beschreibung
verdient ja meistens übertragung von den
trip in die kommentare welcher song das
war dieses team spielt bridges